et voilà il a à foison petit coeur ça ne
va pas tu as la maison salade coeur
alors qu'hier il parle qui paraît très
bonne chose 3d oblige c'est le moment de
faire une sélection pour les fêtes de
fin d'année pour vous dire un petit peu
quelles sont mes produits coups de coeur
les produits qui m'ont marqué qui sont
actuels
vous êtes une sélection de six
smartphones une monde connecté deux
tablettes un casque deux ordinateurs et
un robot je vous garde le meilleur pour
la fin
il vous en dit pas plus tout de suite je
mets un peu le contexte aujourd'hui
c'est pas de dire les six smartphones
que je vous présente par exemple sont
les top of the pop
ça correspond à ce que moi j'ai testé au
coup de coeur que j'ai eue au retour
j'en ai c'est pas du tout pour dénigrer
les autres dire que les autres sont pas
bons dans leur gamme de produits il ya
tellement de produits qui sont
franchement bien que voilà faute à une
sélection faut faire des choix
c'est pas objectif c'est comme ça ça
correspond à mes goûts personnels
et justement et je les partage avec vous
on va tout de suite commencer par les
smartphones pour les smartphones je les
ai partagé en trois catégories on me le
dirait entrée milieu de gamme milieu de
gamme au diable et ensuite top of the
pop très haut de gamme voile un peu
l'idée dans l'entrée milieu de gamme je
commence avec un premier j'ai trouvé
vraiment vraiment vraiment intéressante
c'est le honor 8x pourquoi les honneurs
8x parce que je trouve que par rapport à
son prix il est vachement bien équilibré
ça smartphone vous pouvez trouver aux
alentours des 249 euros plus ou moins et
je suis toujours toujours assez bluffé
par cette machine parce que il a un
écran qui est énorme
il a un écran de 6,5 pouces il est
toujours hyper actuelle le design est
franchement bien vous avez une petite
encoche sur le haut je le trouve
vraiment très très équilibrée au nord a
fait un excellent boulot dessus que ce
soit pour du gaming que ce soit pour des
photos pour de la vidéo pour du
multimédia pour n'importe quoi pour
aller sur les réseaux sociaux
je trouve que c'est un vrai beau
smartphone est à 250 euros franchement
il est impossible d'être déçus par cette
bécane deuxième produit que j'ai trouvé
aussi vraiment bien j'en ai parlé hier
beaucoup plus longtemps c'était au mois
de juin c'est le chien ont mis leur et
demi note 5
leray 1900 qui a eu un prix il n'y a pas
très longtemps et je comprends pas ce
que c'est vraiment un excellent rapport
qualité prix
c'est un smartphone que vous allez
trouver à 200 euros voire un tout petit
peu moins et un rapport qualité prix il
est complètement imbattable écran 5,99
pouces il fait d'excellentes photos
il tourne très bien c'est vraiment une
super machine
on va maintenant don d'organes avec deux
produits de cette fin d'année qui sont
vraiment top le tout premier c'est celui
que j'utilise en ce moment tant que
téléphone personnel c'est le one + 6 t
elle alors le one plus triste est bien
par là mon mignon je trouve vraiment
bien vraiment vraiment très très très
bien équilibrée et pour voir qui coûtent
moins de 600 euros 599 euros franchement
c'est impossible d'être déçu il a les
meilleurs techno actuelle seul un dragon
à 845 un écran amoled de 6,41 pouces
capteur d'empreintes digitales situé
sous l'écran en termes de photos de
vidéos il marche super bien une
stabilisation d'enfer c'est vraiment une
excellente décale et je trouve qu'il ya
un vrai très très bon rapport qualité
prix et là dessus dans le milieu haut de
gamme c'est impossible d'être déçus et
smartphones il y en a un autre qui est
un peu son rival c'est le au pot rx 17
pro qui est aussi excellent alors on a
moins de performance on l'est sur la
série a700 des snapdragon par contre
l'appareil photo est complètement dingue
marche extrêmement bien même si je
trouve que des fois on il enfin petit
peu trop en faible luminosité ça ça
vient du traitement logiciel mais par
contre c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
efficace elle fait en plus que vous ayez
une caméra pour modéliser en trois
dimensions c'est pas mal alors c'est un
gadget pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore dispo mais ce sera très très très
peu de temps pour voir qu'il ya moins de
600 euros sont aussi c'est un excellent
rapport qualité prix font pas dans le
détail de tous ces produits parce qu'on
en a déjà parlé je vous ai mis les liens
en bas des vidéos dédiées comme ça vous
pouvez aller voir les tests complets
voir réellement ce qu'ils leur ponte ce
qu'il en est si vous ne les connaissez
pas et si votre avis est pas déjà fait
là dessus en fait on continue dans mon
amour on n'arrive carrément dans le haut
de gamme très haut
yam et l'homme n'arrive carrément dans
les photos fondeur photophone lorsqu'il
m'a vraiment vraiment mais vraiment
bloqué en cette fin d'année c'est le
mail d'un pro de huawei je trouve tout
simplement incroyable d'ailleurs je dois
sortir d'ici très peu de temps la vidéo
test photo vidéo ce qu'ils aiment manger
je traîne un petit peu là dessus mais
c'est vrai que j'ai vraiment pris du
temps je trouve qu'il est vraiment
vraiment vraiment excellent sur tous les
points
en termes de performances en termes nous
forcément de fluidité en termes
d'autonomie en terre de photos vidéos là
c'est pareil c'est l'explosion c'est le
summum il est vraiment très très bon et
en plus il est vraiment très très beau
le design est super
huawei très très bien réussi sa copie là
dessus et envoie une très très belle
montée en gamme de huawei alors elle est
pris aussi montent en gamme on est sur
des smartphones qui sont aux alentours
des 1000 euros un tout petit peu moins
tout petit peu plus enfin il frôle avec
le numéro ça dépend qui peut ou est-ce
que vous allez le trouver mais en tout
cas il ya un vrai vrai vrai beau progrès
cette année qui a été fait par wade
notamment sur les vins pro c'était déjà
énorme
le mail d'un pro c'est carrément
l'extase j'adore vraiment s'est produit
ensuite aux produits qui m'a vraiment
bluffé sur cette fin d'année s'est
doutée de ces samsung c'est le galaxy
note 9 alors le galaxy note 9 en photo
on est sur le même capteur soient les
même capteur que sur le s9 plus mais je
trouve qu'ils vont encore plus loin
notamment l utilisation du spl le fait
de pouvoir utiliser comme petite
télécommande c'est vraiment très
pratique il ya un vrai confort de
visionnage leur après c'est énorme en
pas se mentir galaxy note 9 c'est
franchement énorme mais pour tous ceux
qui aiment le format fable est je trouve
que c'est un excellent produit d'écran
qui complètement maîtrisé la dalle super
amoled de samsung est incroyable elle
est vraiment belle
l'audio et hop la photo/vidéo jeudi
c'est génial pour le multimédia c'est
incroyable enfin pour moi c'est vraiment
une bécane qui est aussi super bien et
qu'on retrouve aux alentours de 1000
euros on a donc six produits côté
smartphones maintenant je vais vous
parler de monde connecté parce que j'ai
eu un vrai beau coup de coeur sur une
montre collectés alors qu'on essayait
plusieurs cette année bon il y en a que
je trouvais sympa je trouve franchement
bien mais en une que j'ai adoré c'est la
galaxie watch de samsung
j'approuve
vraiment bien des gens termes de design
elle est superbe la navigation est
complètement incroyable tout ce qu'on
peut faire avec les applications qu'on
peut télécharger brad que ce soit pour
le sport bien évidemment pour la santé
connecter pour le multimédia
je trouve que c'est vraiment un objet
qui est très complet très pratique et en
plus de ça elle donne l'heure vous la
trouvez à 329 euros voilà chez rechange
aux amis bien sûr tous les liens en bas
dans la description également des
produits qui m'ont beaucoup plu côté
tablette alors je vous parle pas de
l'ipad fraude cette année parce que je
ne les ai pas testé donc on va le mettre
un peu de côté et j'ai testé d'autres
produits mais y'en a vraiment qui m'ont
plu sont deux produits de chez microsoft
alors il y en a un qui est très actuelle
c'est la surface go parce que on un peu
la frontière de la petite bureautique au
niveau d'un pc avec le clavier qu'il
faut acheter en plus avec la souris
qu'il faut acheter en plus mais une fois
que vous avez la config complète je
trouve que c'est vraiment bien pour la
petit bourg aux tic et la maison pour du
travail de la prise de notes pour faire
un coup tout ce que vous voulez juste la
tablette pour le côté multimédia ça
marche franchement bien il faut qu'à une
vraie belle expérience là dessus et
c'est un produit qui est vraiment très
très bien aussi de la par microsoft en
terme de budget la tablette mais il faut
compter 5 199 euros c'est pas hyper
cadeaux par contre derrière ça marche
bien il ya de belles techno donc ça va
ça fonctionne
après y en a une autre qui m'a aussi
beaucoup plus toujours chez microsoft
mais beaucoup plus cher c'est la surface
pro s'adresse pas forcément aux mêmes
personnes
on a d'autres exigences on va faire
autre chose comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est un matériel qui est dédié ou
professionnel mais je la trouve vraiment
bien
très complète très puissant très
performante c'est vraiment un produit
qui m'a beaucoup bluffé et pour toutes
les personnes qui cherchent ou tablettes
format professionnelle la surface pro et
topissime en terme de budget c'est un
peu plus cher on va la trouver autour
des 900 euros bien sûr il faut rajouter
pour les accessoires on va rapidement
dépassé les 1000 euros mais par contre à
ce prix là vous serez absolument pas
déçu il ya d'autres produits qui m'a
beaucoup plu au point de vue de l'audio
c'est le dernier casque de sony c'est le
sony w/h mille je bouffe toujours le nom
ce fait le souvenir w/h nil xm3 autant
j'adore le casque pourtant je déteste le
nom ce que je trouve que vraiment su
hyper hyper compliqué vous allez en
boutique si vous n'avez pas noté sur un
bout de papier vous avez par le vendeur
bonjour
je voudrais le casque sony à réduction
de bruit et vous savez là le mhc mx3
voilà ça sert un petit peu compliqué par
contre à côté de ça le whh 1000x m3
c'est ça rentre à force super
franchement assez incroyable il y avait
déjà les versions précédentes réunions
bruce a fonctionné très très bien il ya
de la très belle réduction de bruit
ailleurs chez bose également mais là je
trouve que autant la qualité de son elle
est vraiment bluffante traître est
incroyable autant la réduction de bruit
est complètement magnifique ne serait-ce
que mettre le casque pas maître de
musique justin carey de son bruit on
sent à la limite à un peu enfermé
si vous êtes claude kross pas forcément
fait pour vous mais je trouve qu'il a un
côté très apaisant vous vous posez dans
le métro d'un transport en commun dans
ce que vous voulez vous le posez d'or
hu à l'élite sud zen c'est je trouve que
c'est vraiment ils perdent le fond et
c'est vraiment très très bien fait il ya
un excellent boulot qui a été fait par
sony là dessus 5 à ce qui va forcément
cadeau qu'on va trop autour des 350
euros par contre franchement la qualité
est là et vous serez pas déçus il ya
maintenant deux ordinateurs qui m'ont
bien plu
cette année alors autant essayer
plusieurs mais deux qui ont vraiment
retenu l'attention
le premier c'est un produit de chez dell
c'est le xps 13
alors vous avez deux format 4k ou full
hd pour les full hd ça fera déjà très
très très bien la faire mais je trouve
que c'est une bécane qui est hyper
complète vous avez de la performance
vous avez un design très compact il y
adeux l'autonomie c'est vraiment une
très belle machine
le tarif est pas complètement dingue
entre mille 1400 euros vous avez quelque
chose qui est franchement très très bien
il ya notre produit qui m'a bluffé cette
année c'est asus zen book pro 15 pouces
avec le screen pas de la bécane en elle
même est franchement bien mais là où on
va beaucoup plus loin
c'est sur l'innovation avec le screen
pad asus va vraiment dans le bon sens
l'idée de révolutionner des partis comme
le trackpad
il ya une vraie réflexion qu'elle s'est
faite autour de ce trackpad en me disant
qu'est ce qu'on peut en faire
ou est-ce qu'on peut l'emmener quelles
innovations pas emmener sur le pc
sachant que le pc avait pas forcément
énormément d'innovation ces dernières
années autant on a vu chez apple la
touch barre
l'idée d'avoir mis à ce crime pad
foucault c'est vraiment une excellente
idée il ya beaucoup de cas d'usagé
beaucoup de choses intéressantes il ya
beaucoup de raccourcis et rien que pour
ça je pense que c'est vraiment une très
très belle des cannes et d'autant plus
quand pris lé patron va placer 1280
euros voire un peu plus en fonction de
la config
c'est franchement un très bel ordinateur
et maintenant tu américain produit que
je vous ai pas encore présenté c'est un
produit
la maison depuis mois de septembre que
j'ai en fait j'ai pas encore sortie de
vidéos dessus je trouve juste dingue
c'est révolutionnaire c'est un excellent
produit c'est un robot pour la maison en
bois qui fait plein de choses il est là
il est beau voilà il a à chaque fois son
petit coeur c'est votre nouveau pote à
la maison sans vainqueur alors piqueur
il parle du karité plein de choses
kicker allume le vidéoprojecteur la
lumière fut alors là vous ne voyez pas
mais il ya deux vidéos proches qui est
là elle est tournée il faut que je
baisse la lumière qui courait la vidéo
projecteurs allumée je peux venir régler
ici l'orientation grâce à mon
application alors normalement ce qu'il
me faudrait c'est tout autre chose il
faudrait en réalité un mur tout blanc ou
alors une toile enfin voilà ça serait
beaucoup mieux mais on peut vraiment
complètement le piloter à la voix kicker
fait beaucoup de choses kicker est un
vidéo projecteur et voilà il est temps
alors ça c'est vraiment bien parce que
kicker en réalité c'est un petit robot
qui est complètement autonome il est sur
ses roues la wii ces petites roulettes
il franchit les portes ils se déplacent
il est vraiment cool et il a vraiment
plein plein plein plein de points
positifs
là vous avez un vidéo projecteur qui
complètement orientable à 90 degrés vous
avez également une caméra intégrée ce
qui vous permet lorsque vous le pilote à
distance de voir exactement ce qui se
passe chez vous sur le dessus vous avez
une caméra à 360 degrés qui vous permet
de toujours savoir ce qui se passe chez
vous parce qu'en fait son petit coeur
qui a plusieurs fonctionnalités kicker
il vous sert d'appareils multimédia déjà
forcément vous allez pouvoir regarder de
la vidéo où vous voulez que ce soit
netflix ce soit youtube que ce soit la
télé donc tous vos replays et vous les
mettez comme vous voulez vous les
projeter où vous voulez et ce qui est
super cool avec liqueur c'est que ça
complètement cartographier votre maison
qui sait exactement où sont les pièces
vous enregistrez les lieux vous voulez
qu'ils soient les spots complètement
adapté nous dit viens te mettre dans le
salon pour faire une vidéo proche de ce
que vous voulez il vient exactement à
l'endroit ils se positionnent ils
orientent la vidéo projet exactement
comme il le faut et ça c'est vraiment
bien tant d'expériences d'autant plus
que vous avez du son ça va jusqu'à 117
décibels 117 décibels vous avez tué tous
vos voisins
mais par contre vous mettez la puissance
que vous voulez vraiment une vraie belle
qualité audio
alors tout ça on va le détail et plus
tard ce que je veux faire le test pour
vraiment vous puissiez vous en rendre
compte
il m'a fallu un petit peu de temps pour
prendre en main pour dire bétail un
petit robot à la maison qu'est ce que je
fais avec et comment il marche c'est
plutôt cool temps puisque c'est une
start up française qui le développe donc
franchement c'est hyper hyper hyper
intéressant donc à tous côté multimédia
il ya un côté vidéosurveillance kicker
qu'on vous n'êtes pas là de se balader
chez vous et dès qu'il voit un truc qui
est bizarre paf qui vous alerte sur vos
smartphones il ya ça qui pose problème
la fenêtre est ouverte une intrusion il
vous a l'air ça c'est franchement bien
il ya d'autres applications c'est
marrant avec vous pouvez par exemple
utiliser comme réveil matin il va venir
dans votre chiot il va vous réveiller
avec une petite vidéo avec de la musique
etc ce que vous voulez enfin il ya
vraiment plein visage à faire c'est un
robot évolutif il ya très peu de temps
nous il n'y avait pas la voix il ya eu
un bug ait maintenant mais la voix il
peut nous parler de raconter des trucs
il se déplacera s'attachant ça c'est
assez rigolo c'est pas seulement vidéo
proches sur pattes qui se déplace et qui
se déplace plutôt pas mal c'est vraiment
un petit compagnon à la maison et qui
vaut aux grands comme aux petits ou pour
regarder les films je les lis sur mon
fils je mets au dessus de son lit au
plafond je le mets ces dessins animés
sur youtube qu'ils venir il est heureux
c'est un dry pacha kicker on va reparler
très prochainement dont je vous invite à
vous abonner c'est quand même un robot
10 août 1792 euros les turcs on ya goûté
on a du mal à s'en passer voilà peu pour
cette sélection de fin d'année sélection
de produits coup de coeur produits qui
m'ont vraiment plu et moi sur cette
année dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez quels sont vos produits coups de
coeur en 2018 quels sont les produits
que vous avez acheté les produits vous
auriez voulu acheter il ya des choses
qui vous ont vraiment marqué vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire je
vous ai fait ma sélection à vous de
faire la vôtre si ces produits vous
intéresse je vous aimais bien évidemment
toutes mes vidéos tests directement bas
lé lien pour aller voir les produits les
acheter s'ils ne font plaisir et le test
de kicker nahla kicker va arriver très
très très prochainement donc restez
connectés et d'ici là n'hésitez pas à
les regarder mes différentes playlist
pour découvrir pleins d'autres produits
parce que franchement cette fin d'année
elle est complètement hallucinante
soyez sages amusez vous bien et à très
bientôt ciao